voilà pour la politique au niveau
économique la région du nord a encore
l'image d'une zones sinistrées notamment
dans le domaine de l'emploi avec 14 7%
de taux de chômage mais en fait laurent
des bassins d'activité très spécifiques
se sont développées le meilleur exemple
lisais dans le domaine de la santé il ya
six ans lille s'est dotée d'un parc
d'activités installée à côté du centre
hospitalier de nombreuses entreprises
françaises et étrangères s'y sont
installés et il est très vite devenu un
pôle d'excellence en matière de
recherche
là où d'ailleurs le cnrs prépare déjà la
médecine de demain
reportage de lionel coutu et de
christophe la bienvenue dans le monde de
l'infiniment petit on va vraiment voir
des choses extrêmement petit et ben on
regarde on sait au microscope ça permet
de voir des motifs qui sont de la taille
du micro alors pour être clair dès de la
taille du millième de millimètre
on a mis des micromoteurs qui sont
réalisés ici est que ces micro moteur je
vous parle toujours de petites
dimensions excusez moi font 100 microns
de diamètre alors 100 microns qu'est ce
que c'est c'est un dixième de millimètre
c'est un coin cheveux veulent plus
beaucoup faut que je fasse attention
et lorsqu'on regarde le diamètre du
cheveu ça correspond diamètre du moteur
que je vais vous montrer ce monde un
million de fois plus petit qu'une pièce
de 5 centimes va changer notre futur car
les applications réelles de ces
trouvailles sont déjà connu ce type de
moteur on peut les mettre dans les têtes
de cathéters et mettre un petit outil
dessus par exemple pour aller faire une
petite incision une petite intervention
chirurgicale
donc c'est une des avancées possibles de
ce type de technologie pour le bien-être
et pour les applications de type santé
le cnrs de lille est déjà à la pointe de
la recherche sur la santé
le biopôle de la ville prend forme la
fac de médecine a été construite à côté
des hôpitaux
c'est donc naturellement que le parc
eurasanté s'est installé ici pour
attirer les entreprises du monde médical
en 5 ans une vingtaine de sociétés dont
8 étrangères se sont implantés 400
emplois ont été créés
lille il ya cinq ans effectivement
apparaissez comme une région qui était
pas forcément une métropole pas
forcément avec un accent tu es très
important mais depuis on a fait la
démonstration que tous ses atouts dans
le domaine de la recherche dans le
domaine industriel lui permettait de
faire face à une concurrence
internationale et d'être parmi les
leaders européens
c'est pourquoi le laboratoire diagast a
ouvert ses portes au coeur d'eurasanté
ce leader mondial dans la distribution
de kits de détermination de groupe
sanguin
il trouve son intérêt le site aura santé
a été choisi d'une part pour trouver des
complémentarités avec les autres
entreprises du site et enfin je dirais
surtout être à proximité d'un centre
hospitalier universitaire qui est à la
fois un client important et potentiel
pour diagast est aussi une source
d'innovation dans l'est déjà
autre atout d'eurasanté l'aide qu'ils
proposent aux start up du monde médical
ce simulateur laser pour étudiants en
ophtalmologie n'aurait peut-être jamais
vu le jour pour la santé nous a aidés
sur toute la phase de montage du dossier
création du plan de développement du
business plan de la partie financière et
recherche des premiers partenaires
financiers aujourd'hui les projets
affluent pour construire la médecine du
futur
vingt nouvelles sociétés devraient être
créés d'ici la fin de l'année